tasty is challenging me to create a
three-course meal for four guests for 20
[Music]
the great thing about this one is this
thing came in at
and 21 cents
[Music]
hi i'm andrew i'm the test kitchen
manager here at tasty and after a long
day of working in the kitchen there's
nothing i like more than sitting down
for a meal with my wife but ordering in
and going out can be a little bit
expensive so today i'm challenging
myself to make five weeknight meals 4-2
for only dollars all right
so i was able to find everything that i
needed at the store for
18.76 which means i came in under budget
so the dishes i'm going to be making are
a sweet potato and chickpea curry a one
pot chicken fajita rice bake and to
close out the week i'm gonna make my
favorite thing chicken piccata so
instead of having five meals for five
nights i'm gonna stretch my budget a
little bit more and have two meals twice
and then end out the week with something
a little bit special and helping me out
today are going to be a few pantry
staples which i also recommend that you
have in your own home those are butter
olive oil salt and pepper and with all
that said it's time to start cooking
okay so first thing i have to do is
break down this whole chicken which it
looks a little intimidating but it's
actually a lot easier than you think and
very inexpensive you want to lay it down
with the legs facing you you'll take
your knife and make an incision in the
skin right here between the breast and
the leg it should just come apart really
easy now do the same thing on the other
side the leg joints are exposed so what
i'm going to do is i'm going to put my
hands underneath here and then i'm going
to pop the thighs right out of the
socket i want to take my knife and i
want to cut right on the opposite side
of that closest to the breast very
carefully obviously use a sharp knife
when you're doing this it makes
everything easier so here you have your
chicken leg you have your thigh and your
drumstick now same thing with the other
one find the ball joint get in there
with your knife carefully and there you
have both separated so i'm going to set
this aside just over here i'm going to
bring the legs back to my board turn
them around and you'll see right here
there's this fat line that's the exact
place you want to cut and separate the
leg and the thigh and you'll actually
feel it with your knife and just go
straight through one leg
one thigh so now i'm going to focus on
the white meat the easiest way to get
the breast off the chicken you have your
breast plate here what you want to do is
you want to cut on the opposite side of
that closest to the breast you want to
remove
and just make a small incision this part
is all about the small incisions getting
as much meat as possible that's
obviously the goal we want to stretch
our budget so what i'm going to do is
i'm going to keep going down i'm
literally just riding along the rib cage
trim back any of this fat from the skin
that you don't need remove this breast
goes through the skin it's all about
small strokes and there you have one
chicken breast the other one same thing
ride the rib cage when you can trim back
any of this fat cut around the wing
there you go two chicken breasts all
right so my chicken is broken down and
the nice thing about this is i'm gonna
be able to use all these parts of the
chicken in different dishes to really
stretch my budget but i'm not gonna
discard this carcass this is gonna
become a delicious chicken stock
our chicken stock is really just gonna
be chicken salt pepper and water you
could use aromatics if you want onions
carrot celery most chicken stocks have
them but since it isn't in our budget we
have to work with what we have so i have
the chicken to the pot then i'm gonna
add water just to cover a pinch of salt
a couple cracks of fresh pepper we're
going to let this come to a boil bring
it down to a simmer and let it simmer
for about four hours to extract as much
chicken flavor as possible i guess i'll
see you guys in about four hours so what
i wanna do is strain this out get all
the chicken bits out and just have a
nice clean stock be careful once all the
pieces come out
let's taste it
[Music]
it's actually really nice i'm just gonna
add a little bit more salt just for
myself stock is all strained out it's
seasoned to my liking i'm gonna use this
in the majority of my cooking today
whatever's left over i'll keep in my
fridge for a week and then i'll throw it
in the freezer if i don't get around to
it so now it's time to dive into our
first recipe first thing i'm gonna make
is a sweet potato and chickpea curry
this is gonna be enough for two dinners
for the two of us so first thing we
wanna do get our heat going let's go
over medium heat we'll add some olive
oil so once your oil is nice and warm
and shimmering we're gonna add in some
diced onion i'm gonna give this a stir
just to get the onions all coated in the
olive oil
i'm gonna season it with a little bit of
salt
just because i like to season every step
of the way it's guaranteed excellent
flavor but we don't want the onions to
burn we just want them to sweat out a
little bit and soften just to bring out
their natural flavors
while those are cooking i'm going to
grate some fresh ginger right into the
pot most people think you have to peel
the ginger but i find that it's a bit of
a taxing step so we're just going to
grate it straight in i'm going to give
this a stir
get those flavors all together looks
like our onions are good to go what i
want to do now is i want to add in some
freshly minced garlic again just adding
extra flavor give it a stir
you just want to cook it until it's
fragrant you don't want to burn it it'll
get really bitter nobody likes that so
now we're going to add in our curry
powder what we're doing is we're
toasting the curry powder we're really
drawing out that flavor and making the
flavors really warm now it's going to
taste good the first day but the
leftovers are going to taste even better
when these flavors have had time to
marry and sit in the fridge together
there's nothing better than that the
curry is nice and toasted so what i want
to do now is add everything else so we
have our chickpeas for a little bit of
protein and we have our sweet potatoes
i'm gonna season
all right so we're gonna get these
vegetables coated in that beautifully
toasted curry powder and now i'm gonna
add some coconut milk give that a stir
i'm gonna do a little seasoning and next
we're going to take this delicious
chicken stock that we already made we're
going to add this right in here now
we're using chicken stock because we
wanted to stretch the chicken and and
save our budget but if you do have it in
the budget to buy some vegetable stock
this would be a wonderful vegetarian
dish we're gonna bring this to a boil
we're gonna reduce it down to a simmer
let it simmer for about 15 minutes until
the sweet potatoes are perfectly cooked
through my curry is simmering away i'm
actually going to toast some extra curry
powder just to add a little extra flavor
so we can get some curry in a hurry we
have our heat our oil just a little bit
so now the oil's nice and hot i'm gonna
add in our curry powder and we're just
gonna carefully toast this until it
starts to smell fragrant and nutty like
i said this is gonna add so much curry
flavor to this already delicious curry
this will happen really quick too so
don't even blink
safe to say that that is smelling
fragrant and delicious and it's ready to
get added to our curry now i'm going to
add in some spinach and i'm just going
to cook it for about two minutes till it
gets nice and wilted careful when adding
this in it's going to look like a lot
but it's going to shrink down to nothing
and then just to finish this off a
little bit i'm going to add a little bit
of acid so i'm going to add some lime
juice all right this looks really good i
have two tupperware containers here full
of cooked rice rice is really
inexpensive and i'm also going to use it
in another dish i'm making today if you
want to check out our tasty 101 video on
how to cook rice
click below so what i'm going to do is
i'll spoon my curry over the rice do it
over the pot curry will stain your
countertop this is going to be really
really good in a couple days so i'm
going to let these cool i'm going to
transfer them to the refrigerator for
later on in the week the rest of this
i'll heat up later on when my wife comes
to try let's move on to the next recipe
the next recipe we're gonna do is a one
pot chicken and fajita rice bake this
recipe is really nice because we can use
the majority of the chicken that we
already broke down and then we can use
the other half of the rice that we
didn't use during the curry recipe and
like with the curry this is going to
cover two meals during the week i'm just
going to add a little bit of our olive
oil going to want to use enough to just
coat a nice thin layer on the bottom of
the pan so season our chicken salt and
pepper on both sides so we'll flip it
over with some tongs we're going to use
two of the drumsticks two of the thighs
and one of the chicken breasts the other
chicken breasts we're gonna save for our
uh final dish of the week we're just
gonna use a store-bought packet of
fajita seasoning i'm gonna use about a
third of it to season the chicken and
then i'll use the remainder of it later
on in the dish same thing will go in on
both sides we really want to get as much
flavor out of this as possible and these
fajita spice packets i grew up on these
things everything my mother made had a
spice packet whether it be tacos or
chili okay so now i'm going to rub the
chicken get all those spices into it get
under the skin if you can any excess
spices on the sheet tray you can just
pat right onto there just want to make
sure we're getting every inch of this
delicious chicken that you spent all the
time breaking down coated with the spice
if you have any extra left over just do
the same thing dump it on we'll really
get it in there our chicken is all
seasoned it's time to sear it up so i'm
gonna add everything in skin side down
so we can get that nice crispy skin you
could use skinless chicken thighs but i
just really really love crispy chicken
skin and a lot of the fat is going to
drip down into the rice which is going
to make it taste
so good evenly spaced apart you don't
want to crowd the pan too much so i'm
going to let this go for about two to
three minutes per side just until it
gets nice and golden brown we'll flip it
over and then we'll finish off the dish
i'm just gonna take a little peek under
the chicken just to make sure it's
getting nice and brown not burning if it
starts to burn you can move it around
the pan every pan kind of has a
different hot spot so cool we're almost
there you don't really have to worry
about cooking the chicken through at
this point you're really just getting
some color on the skin it adds a lot of
flavor cooks out a lot of those spices a
lot of the cooking is going to happen a
little later on in the recipe our
chicken is nice and golden brown on one
side
oh that's perfect
so we're just gonna do the same thing on
the other side let it go for about two
to three minutes i'm gonna go ahead and
take it out of the pan transfer it to a
nice clean sheet tray i know you can't
smell it but this smells so good and you
don't have to tell anybody it's a fajita
packet our chicken's done so i'm gonna
finish off the rest of the dish we're
gonna start with our vegetables sliced
onion and green bell peppers green is
actually the cheapest one in the store
so that's what we're working with today
we've already built all this flavor in
the pan you've got chicken juices you've
got some of the flavor from that i'm
just gonna add the vegetables to our pan
we're gonna season with salt and then
we're just gonna cook these down until
they're nice and soft in about two to
three minutes we don't have to worry
about cooking these all the way through
because it's gonna finish off in the
oven just give them a nice toss get it
all coated in that already built flavor
in the pan so while these onions sweat
they're gonna release a lot of their
natural juices which is gonna pick up a
lot of that really nice flavor in the
pan so to these vegetables i'm gonna add
about a cup and a half of rice i like to
add the rice in at this step just so it
toasts a little bit gets a little bit of
nutty also adds extra flavor and then to
this i'm going to add the remainder of
that fajita packet i was talking about
earlier give that a stir
get everything coated so once all the
rice is nice and coated in the spices
we're gonna add in our homemade chicken
stock we're gonna go in with about two
and a quarter cups of this chicken stock
give it a mix let it come to a little
simmer scrape off the bottom of the pan
if there's any nice brown bits all right
this is simmering so i'm gonna go ahead
and add our chicken pieces back in so
i'm just going to nestle these in here
just to make sure that it cooks all the
way through and don't forget all these
beautiful juices so i turned up the heat
i'm going to go ahead and cover this
with some foil a fun little trick to
make sure the foil gets nice and tight
pinch the bottom and twist all right and
this is good to go we're going to
transfer to a 400 degree oven for 35 to
40 minutes until the internal
temperature of the chicken is 165
degrees fahrenheit
oh my god that looks so good i'm gonna
take half of this and i'm gonna save it
for later on in the week let's get the
thighs
my favorite cut of the chicken that
should be enough and then we'll get some
of this delicious
rice and vegetable
situation oh it smells so good i don't
know if i can wait until later on in the
week so when it's time to serve i also
bought sour cream salsa and some lime to
really jazz up the flavors a little bit
all right i'll serve this later when
claire comes here and now we're ready to
move on to our final
recipe our final dish of the week one of
my all-time favorites chicken piccata so
first things first we gotta tackle this
lemon i always say when life gives you
lemons make chicken piccata i'm gonna go
ahead and i'm gonna cut this lemon in
half crosswise i'm going to cut this guy
in half these guys i'm just going to cut
into really thin slices about an eighth
of an inch thick so a little trick when
you're cutting any vegetable or fruit is
to just keep your hand in a nice claw
formation so i'm going to go ahead i'm
going to transfer these to a really
small bowl these are going to go into
our sauce later on in the dish and the
juice of this is actually gonna go into
our sauce later on as well so that's our
lemon now we're gonna move on to the
chicken we have our last chicken breast
here you're probably wondering why do
you have one chicken breast how's this
gonna make two meals we're actually
gonna go ahead and cut this in half and
it's going to make two thinner chicken
breasts so to take off the skin you
don't have to do anything fancy you can
really just peel it back use some force
and voila so to get two cutlets out of
this one chicken breast you want to take
your knife you want to use your other
hand as force and then really thin
strokes through the center of this
chicken breast making sure that we get
all the pieces you can kind of see you
can open it up this way and then slowly
slice away at it so you get two perfect
chicken cutlets
one and two we're gonna pound these out
really thin it helps the chicken cook a
little bit faster and it's also very
traditional to chicken piccata i'm gonna
take one large piece of plastic wrap and
i'm gonna place it over top of these
chicken breasts with the flat end of the
meat melt we're just going to pound away
these chicken breasts what i like to do
is instead of going directly down i like
to almost go in an upward motion and i
would say you're looking for these
chicken cutlets to be about a quarter of
an inch thick this may seem like a
really small amount for two people but
it's going to be over a bed of pasta
it's going to have a really delicious
and buttery sauce so you'll be all good
so i'm just going to season it with salt
and pepper give it a little flip of dip
a little sprinkle a little pepper i'm so
excited for this this is literally one
of my favorite dishes i put some oil in
the pan we have to dredge our chicken in
a little bit of flour so we used
all-purpose flour here very inexpensive
at the store i'm going to add this to
the pan
lay the chicken cutlet down away from
you so the oil doesn't splatter and get
this guy nice and coated and now we're
gonna cook these for two to two and a
half minutes per side get nice and
golden brown then we'll flip do the same
thing and then we're on to our sauce
all right our chicken is done
nice and golden brown on both sides just
gonna transfer this to a clean plate
with a pair of clean tongs all right so
it's time to make our sauce into the
same pan we're gonna use all the chicken
drippings as our oil we're gonna cook
some garlic about two cloves of garlic
we just wanna cook that until fragrant
we don't want it to burn we're already
starting to brown so i'm going to add in
our capers the capers are nice and briny
to add a nice salty note to this chicken
piccata also one of the classic
ingredients in the sauce
i'm going to add in our lemon slices
these are going to cook down and release
their juices naturally so when your
garlic starts to get a little too golden
brown we're gonna add in our chicken
stock
this will stop the cooking it'll also
bring out a lot of the flavors lemon is
the very iconic flavor in chicken
piccata so just to really drive that
home a little bit i'm gonna add some
freshly squeezed lemon juice so we're
just gonna let this cook down for a
couple minutes until it's reduced by
half so the thing about chicken piccata
and me is this is actually the first
thing i actually learned how to make i
think i just kind of always gear towards
the lemon flavor of things i really love
super acidic things so when i first
learned how to cook i was like that's
the first thing i'm gonna learn how to
do so the sauce is reduced down by half
i'm just gonna turn off the heat and
then we're gonna add our butter so this
is about two tablespoons of butter
ideally a nice cold pot of butter and
what i like to do is i actually like to
swirl it into the sauce this way it
gradually just kind of thickens the
sauce stops it from breaking
i can smell the capers the garlic's
really coming through you can see how
creamy and emulsified that butter is in
the sauce it's really really nice all
right that looks perfect our sauce is
done it's exactly where i want it to be
just to add a little bit of color i'm
gonna throw in some fresh chopped
parsley save a little bit for garnish
too turn off the heat and now it's time
to plate it all up i'm gonna serve it
over pasta pasta really hearty super
inexpensive so pasta on the plate and
then i just wanna let me place the
chicken breast over top like so and then
use our delicious sauce
spoon all of that over top this is also
gonna become a sauce for the pasta too
make sure we get it right on nice on top
there i'm going to put more capers on
mine because i love capers i'm just
going to finish it off with a little bit
more fresh parsley just for some color
and that's it the final plate of the
week
we did it we've got everything plated up
we've got five weeknight meals four two
for just under twenty dollars now all
that's left to do is to have claire come
in and try it
mmm that's delicious hearty enough for
oh yeah and you can eat this two days
out of the week done we have a one pot
chicken
fajita rice bake perfect all right ooh
good color you taught me that i don't
know what i'm talking about
good yeah that's really good wow that
chicken is cooked perfectly this is like
our first four days okay and then
finally on friday i made you my favorite
which is the chicken piccata ah italian
makes sense
mmm
good right oh my god
hi i'm io and i'm a private chef
typically when i work for clients i have
a really big or unlimited budget but
tasty is challenging me to create a
three-course meal for four guests for 20
which honestly feels like a little bit
of a setup wish me luck
so for the first course i'm gonna set my
oven to 425 and i'm actually going to
crisp up this prosciutto i found for
four dollars so we have a nice crunchy
topping that gives our tartine some
depth and some texture next i got the
bread for one dollar and i'm gonna make
the base of the tartine by covering both
sides of the bread and olive oil and
also toasting it in the oven with the
prosciutto to save time so the
prosciutto is gonna go in the oven for
about six minutes and the toast are
gonna go in the oven for anywhere
between 7 to 10 minutes while those are
in the oven we're going to make our
whipped lemon ricotta first we're going
to put the ricotta into the food
processor a lot of food processors need
some kind of liquid or something in the
bottom to get them going so i'm going to
add my tablespoon of olive oil pretty
close to the blades good good good tip
is to use one ingredient twice so for
this stuff i'm actually only going to
use the zest of this lemon and i'll use
the juice later so i'm going to add a
little salt and then i'm going to start
this bad boy
oh i'm actually gonna let this sit for a
second and move on to getting my
zucchini ready for our presentation i'm
actually gonna create zucchini ribbons
which will give us a little height too
and this is what you want for your peel
so i'm gonna season these with pepper
and i'm gonna add a little salt because
everything needs a little salt and just
a hint of olive oil because it's going
to make them easier to twirl and
basically you're just going to give it a
little toss it doesn't need a lot and
you want to be really gentle with them
because you can overwork the zucchini
and then they just get watery and they
get really flat and we want to keep that
crunch and that height i'm gonna go get
my toast and my prosciutto and let's put
together course number one so the first
thing you're gonna wanna do with your
hot bread is rub it with fresh garlic
cloves and i know if you've never done
this it's like what but this gives it so
much flavor hold on tight to the garlic
and keep rubbing it and you want to do
that to all of them both sides we're
going to take about two tablespoons of
ricotta and just scoop a big dollop
right in the middle and i know some
chefs and foodies are like that looks a
hot mess i know that is why we have this
and i'm actually just gonna create some
nice little hills and valleys for my
bikini to live in all right so our next
step is definitely like the showstopper
of this course so what you're going to
do for your ribbon take a little piece
you can wrap it around a finger
or a pair of tweezers if you're that
kind of shelf and you have them you just
slide it off you just want to create a
little ribbon and when you put it down
it just stays
and basically we're gonna do that two to
three more times for each toast we're
gonna take half of one piece of our
prosciutto and we're just gonna give it
a little crumble and once you have a
couple little pieces you're just gonna
lightly sprinkle them over your zucchini
toast so after the prosciutto we're
gonna top it with some parsley so the
parsley is pretty much our last step so
i'm just gonna salt and pepper it and
then we can move on to our main course
and the great thing about this one is
this thing came in at
and 21 cents i honestly couldn't believe
it
so for my chicken filling i have a half
a cup of spinach a cup of shredded
mozzarella cheese and a little bit of
minced garlic about one clove okay so
i've mixed up our filling we're just
going to set this aside and we're going
to start pounding out this chicken when
you're pounding out chicken two very
important things
plastic wrap you want one on the bottom
and one on the top and basically this is
just going to protect your chicken from
flying everywhere it's going to protect
everything around you when you're
pounding it out you want to get it about
a quarter of an inch thick and if you do
get a hole or two don't worry about it
because that is what the prosciutto is
here for it's really great stress
reliever too all right and i think we
are about there i'm actually going to go
ahead and season my chicken thigh and i
use the style because styles are always
much cheaper than breasts so our chicken
is seasoned and pounded out i'm going to
get a new piece of plastic wrap and lay
two pieces of prosciutto down i'm just
gonna lay my chicken down inside the
prosciutto and then we're gonna add our
filling and i'm gonna make sure i create
a thin layer all across so you get an
equal amount of cheese and spinach in
one bite tuck your thumbs under the
bottom and you just create a nice tight
roll all the way and if you get a little
filling on the side you know just shove
it back in everyone's going to go
together the good thing about putting
the plastic wrap down first is we're
already ready so i'm actually going to
take the end furthest away from me and
just really tightly roll her up and what
this does is gets the chicken kind of
used to being in this shape and it makes
it a lot easier when it comes time to
sear it
we're sharing them so we can help the
prosciutto get crispy we're going to
lock in our moisture before we put it in
the oven and i'm going to create a
little bit of pond at the bottom of the
pan which basically means we're going to
get a little bit of brown bits so when
we deglaze it to make our sauce it'll
have a little bit of the meat flavor
which just helps tie the whole dish
together
so this is what we want this is golden
brown delicious since i got that on one
side i'm just going to turn them so i
can keep getting
all my sides nice and brown so these are
about ready i actually added some
toothpicks because they started on roll
a little bit so i'm going to take these
out and transfer them to this pan so we
can put them in the oven for about 15 to
20 minutes at 400 degrees so now we're
going to make our sauce we're going to
slice our peppers so what you're going
to do is just split it in half down the
middle you want to remove the seeds and
the membranes because when we create our
red pepper sauce they're just going to
make it gritty so roasting the pepper is
a really good idea for this sauce
because it's going to give us a ton of
flavor it completely changes the flavor
profile of the pepper for very very
little money so let's go broil these for
two to three minutes once the skin is
nice and black it's time for them to
come out so my peppers are done i put
them in this bowl and wrap them so it
steams them and that skin is just going
to melt off we're going to blend this so
you don't really need it to be like a
nice chop to create more depth of flavor
first we're going to saute this pepper
we're also going to add two cloves of
minced garlic smells great so now i'm
going to deglaze this with our lemon
juice so when we just say deglaze it
literally means pick up all the brown
bits or anything that could be stuck to
the pan so i have a cup and a half of
chicken broth i'm going to add that to
my sauce before we get to blending all
right so this looks ready so i'm just
gonna pour it in the blender
so i'm gonna go ahead and add this back
to our pan and i know this feels like a
lot of steps for a sauce but to me the
sauce is the most important part so now
we're just going to let this come up to
a boil and we're going to turn it down a
little so it doesn't boil over but you
do want it to reduce by about half so
this is reduced so i think we're good to
go the only thing we're missing for this
is something to give it like that
luxurious feel which is where the butter
comes in so i am going to add this very
very cold butter about a tablespoon
tablespoon and a half at a time because
you do not want to break your sauce for
this dish i'm using fettuccine so
basically i'm just going to give it a
nice little twirl in the sauce
all right let's see what this inside
looks like oh that that is sexy so as
you can see when i get into my pasta i
just start creating like just a little
twirl and i'm just going to put it
directly in the center and just drop it
and because we spent all that time
making these pretty rolls we're gonna
stagger them so you can see all of the
pizzas
all we need is a little italian parsley
and finally we're gonna put some fresh
cracked black pepper over the top and
that's our main course surprisingly it
came in at 189 per serving and it looks
amazing i'm excited so let's go ahead
and start on dessert
the first thing i'm gonna do is take a
teaspoon and a half of this gelatin and
i'm just gonna add the gelatin to the
water and then we're gonna let it sit
for about five minutes while that's
happening we're gonna add our half and
half and our sugar and then i'm just
gonna give it a little stir while i
bring it up just under a boil i'm gonna
add our gelatin to it and i'm just gonna
keep stirring it so now we're gonna
strain it and it's just to make sure we
don't get any little bits of gelatin or
anything and make sure it has a nice
creamy mouth feel once our cream has
cooled down a little bit i'm gonna add
it to our cups they're gonna sit at a
really cool angle just another little
plating trick to make them look a little
fancier than they actually are
i have a pound of thawed frozen
strawberries and i'm gonna add them to
my pan and with them i'm going to add a
quarter cup of sugar and a half a cup of
water i'm gonna do this until they come
up just under a boil till they have a
nice bubble to them until some of the
water comes out of the strawberries and
we're just gonna puree it
oh it smells so good this is beautiful
so i'm just gonna put this back we're
going to keep it warm because we're
going to add back in our gelatin
all right this is good to go so i'm
going to go ahead and strain it got some
chunky bits some seeds all the things
from the strawberries so i think we got
it all out and we are ready to set i've
transferred my strawberry puree to a
measuring cup and i'm just going to pour
it over the white part you need to let
this cool a little bit you don't want to
do it while it's hot so i'm going to let
these sit for two to four hours and hope
that i was able to make this pretty and
tasty because that's really the true
test of this right it needs to taste
good and not like it costs 20 dollars
all right that's our strawberry panna
cotta came in at 106
per serving which is insane like i think
it's beautiful so for 20
i was able to create a super seasonal
tartine there's a roasted red pepper
sauce i wrapped my chicken in the same
prosciutto and finally we made this
awesome panna cotta i'm actually really
proud of this you guys i think i did a
pretty good job
okay this is really good
i cannot believe this was a dollar and
six cents it tastes like we really put
some effort for it like like me and
y'all we did this together hey guys it's
katie and this is my husband chris hi
and today we've got a new challenge
i am gonna try to make a gourmet dessert
shopping only at the dollar store wow it
had eggs it had cream cheese butter cake
pans and i now have a plan i'm gonna
make a cheesecake with a strawberry
topping and a coconut cookie crust and
then on top of that i'm gonna have
italian meringue sugar shards candy
crushed up cookies so let's just get
right into it first thing i'm gonna do
is make the coconut cookie crust for the
bottom of our cheesecake take about 16
of them and put them through the food
processor and grind them until they're
nice and fine if you have a small food
processor like mine you'll have to do
this in batches add this to a small bowl
and three tablespoons of melted butter
mix that up until it becomes a nice wet
sand texture and then i've lined an 8x8
cake ban with cooking spray and
parchment paper add our crust to the
bottom make sure you get this nice and
compacted that way it really sticks
together once it sets in the fridge
because this is going to be a no-bake
cheesecake this looks nice and even so
now we're going to move on to making the
filling i got a classic cheesecake mix
from the dollar store and the
instructions are really easy so all we
need to do is add the mix to a bowl and
then eight ounces of cream cheese beat
this until it's smooth and creamy now
we're gonna fold in our whipped topping
all right that looks pretty good add
this to our cake pan
and then use an offset spatula to smooth
it out and make it nice and even i'm
gonna put this in the fridge and move on
to our next step
okay and for our final element of the
actual cheesecake we're gonna make a
strawberry topping now they didn't have
fresh strawberries at this dollar store
i went to but they did have strawberry
jello so the first thing we need to do
is combine one packet with three
quarters cup boiling water mix that
together until the sugar dissolves i'm
doing the speed set method which you
then add cold water and ice
and this is just quickly bringing down
the temperature of the jello so it sets
faster stir that until the mixture
thickens up then remove any leftover ice
with a slotted spoon i'm going to use a
ladle to gently spoon on the jello
mixture to the cheesecake i want to make
a thin layer not a big thick one i think
i ended up using about a half of the
jello mixture
make sure wherever you put this in your
fridge is very flat so that you don't
have like
more jello in one area
don't want that
so the next few things we're going to
make are going to be the garnishes that
go on top of our cheesecake we're going
to measure out about a quarter cup of
sugar and add two tablespoons of water
and swirl that around a bit just so that
all of the sugar meets the water they
get acquainted put that over medium heat
and let that go until it reaches 240
degrees fahrenheit while that heats up
we're gonna whip up one egg white at
room temperature you'll beat this egg
white until you get soft peaks
we've got soft peaks
let's take the temperature okay we're at
240. so with your beaters on we're gonna
slowly pour in the sugar
and then you're gonna turn the mixer up
to high
our meringue is done it's sticking to
the bowl next thing i'm gonna make are
candy glass shards first thing we'll do
is add half a cup of sugar to a saucepan
and then a quarter cup of water so we're
gonna heat this up somewhere between 295
to 300 degrees fahrenheit we want to get
it to the hard crack stage like hard
candy like a jolly rancher so you can
add food coloring to your candy to get
different colors but i'm gonna go for a
more natural look and get that golden
brown caramel color
all right i think we're there so we're
just gonna pour this on some parchment i
have
oh yeah while it's still warm you're
going to tilt your pan up and down and
around to try to spread this out we
don't want thick hard glass we want like
thin delicate shards once it's cooled
take something heavy like a meat mallet
or a fork or a spoon and you can start
hitting it just get out any aggression
that you need to get out but just hit it
and all these cracks
are gonna form
and then it should just peel right off
and then you have these nice little
glass pieces the last thing i'm going to
do is make a [ __ ] which is a french
term for basically a fruit or vegetable
puree that's used as a sauce on the
plate and i feel like every gourmet dish
has it so i'm gonna make my [ __ ] with
strawberry jam and i'm gonna measure out
two tablespoons
then add one teaspoon of water and we'll
mix that right up and then to make sure
there's no clumps in it run it through a
fine mesh strainer
all right looks good all of our elements
are ready to go the only thing left to
do is assemble
this bad boy
i'm going to use a white plate for this
because it's a blank canvas and the
colors are really going to pop off of it
i'm taking my cooley and a pastry brush
and i am going to paint the bottom of
the plate
next we're going to place a thin slice
of cheesecake in the middle we'll just
tuck in anything that fell we'll clean
up those crumbs
i'll top that with crushed wafer cookies
crushed freezer dried strawberries i'm
going to add a couple pieces of candy
then we'll take our candy glass and put
that on top
and then pipe on some meringue my
meringue is not as stiff as i want but i
still think it looks pretty we just have
to keep going so that's what we're gonna
do last but not least i'm gonna add some
coconut pieces
we'll finish this off by adding some
more on the plate and last thing we need
to do is clean it chris
[Music]
here it is whoa
oh my god that looks like something from
a fancy restaurant and you're not saying
that because you're married to me no no
it looks really good if if it didn't i
would say it looked like trash
i really want a taste all right let's
try it all right
oh it's really good
this gore makes the grade
whoa
[Music]
okay we came in under budget multiple
stores a few hacks here and there but i
was able to get everything i needed for
my thanksgiving dinner for
29.93 i have a few pantry staples that i
can use today to help me out i have
olive oil and i have salt and pepper i
don't know how i'm going to do this i
got a few tips and tricks i kind of have
a plan but let's get started
[Music]
i'm going to start with dessert because
i'm going to show you how to save time
and show you how to save some money so i
am going to make a cheaters meringue for
a patty pie i'm using a patty pie
because i want to kind of stay true to
my roots with this so i'm going to start
with a pre-made patty pie to jazz up
this pie a little i'm actually going to
make a cheaters meringue so i have three
room temperature egg whites
marshmallow fluff and i'm gonna whip
this up into soft peaks and then slowly
add in my marshmallow fluff
it smells really good
this is not my ministry which is why
we're doing a cheater's meringue so now
i'm gonna add the marshmallow fluff and
i'm gonna add it slowly about a third at
a time so i don't deflate the egg whites
so this is shiny we have some nice stiff
peaks which is exactly what you want i'm
gonna take large chunks pile it very
very very high
and then i'm just gonna create like some
little hills and valleys some nice peaks
so i'm gonna go put this in the oven at
350 degrees for about 10 to 12 minutes
just to get it brown
we don't have money for a whole turkey
there's also only six guests coming to
this dinner so i'm going to use a turkey
breast i got it pre-seasoned which saved
me a ton of money on spice i won't say i
don't trust that they fully seasoned it
but i will say don't judge me or this
turkey so i'm just gonna give it a
little extra so now i'm gonna sear the
skin side first in an already very very
hot pan so inside this pan i already
have two tablespoons of olive oil and
what you're looking for is just a nice
golden brown delicious crispy crispy
crispy skin make sure the meat is nice
and dry before it goes in your pan this
is what we are looking for crispy skin
golden brown delicious
so now i'm gonna add my aromatics to the
pan this will help us out a lot later so
i have three celery stalks that i cut
into thirds
half of one large yellow onion and six
garlic cloves peeled so i'm gonna take
this guy to the oven at 350 for about 75
minutes until he gets to about 165
degrees but don't worry our turkey's not
going to be dry i'm going to baste it in
its own juices about every 30 minutes or
so so we're going to keep her nice and
moist and ready to go and now we're
going to get into my favorite part and
my whole reason for going to
thanksgiving besides
[Music]
so the first thing i'm going to make is
this cornbread dressing so the first
thing i'm going to do is cook
8 ounces of pork sausage in this pan i
already have it hot i've added some
olive oil to it so i'm just going to
start here my pork sausage also has some
spice to it which is a good way to again
save money on seasoning but get a little
extra flavor so i'm gonna cook this
sausage for about seven to eight minutes
just until i get it nice and brown and
caramelized you want it cooked all the
way because it'll give us a lot of
texture okay so now i'm gonna add in my
celery that same onion we used earlier
and two garlic cloves that we just
minced up and we're just gonna cook this
until the veg gets soft and everything
starts to smell really good i'm also
going to salt this just a tad as we're
moving through it really kick up that
spicy flavor that's in our sausage so my
vegetables are all soft and now i'm
going to add my box cornbread stuffing
normally i would make this myself i'd
make my cornbread first it would be a
whole thing but i had thirty dollars and
we don't have that much time okay this
is looking pretty good so now i'm going
to add a cup and a half of boiling water
and four tablespoons of butter see tell
you always gonna make it taste good so
now i'm gonna cover this for about five
minutes and let it fluff up and absorb
all of that butter we just put in okay
this is actually surprisingly smelling
pretty good i'm really impressed with
this the one thing dressing and stuffing
both have in common is a nice crispy
topping so i'm gonna move this from the
stove top to an oven safe casserole dish
and i'm gonna broil it for about one to
two minutes just to give it a little
crunch all right so next i am going to
make mashed potatoes the craziest thing
about this entire dish is that i got 10
pounds of mashed potatoes for a dollar
and 98 cents so i'm only using about
four pounds of potatoes so after you
cook for everybody your guest leaves you
make you some mashed potatoes for the
next day i'm gonna use a mandolin
because it's faster but if this scares
you which it should if you're not used
to using it you can absolutely use a
knife the best way to cook these is to
cut them very very thin so i'm just
going to slice this entire bowl and then
we're going to move on to boiling them
so you always want to start your
potatoes off in cold water and i'm just
going to salt the water and i'm going to
turn this up all right so my potatoes
are cooked they are strained and now it
is time to turn them into mashed
potatoes if you don't have a rice fair
you can use a potato masher it's nothing
wrong with a rustic potato you could
mash them with a fork just whatever you
have on hand but these are fancy so i'm
going to use this ricer so another great
money saving tip
sour cream typically i would add like
heavy cream or buttermilk something to
give you that tang and the smooth
mouthfeel you get from dairy we don't
have money for that y'all i have a cup
and a half of melted but yes a cup and a
half of thanksgiving of melted butter
and i'm going to add that to my potatoes
i really like doing it by hand because
you get to see it come together and you
just you cook it with a little bit of
love okay so this looks really good we
have turkey we have sweet potatoes and
honestly i think we need some vegetables
so i'm gonna move on to making us some
green beans
so the first thing we're gonna do is
take three cloves of smashed garlic and
we're gonna saute them in our pan with
the green beans so i'm just gonna hit
them with a little salt and then i'm
actually going to steam them in this
chicken stock which is a great way to
add a lot of flavor you don't want to
steam them till they're very soft you
want them to still have a little bit of
bite so my green beans look good they're
nice and tender for the oolala part i'm
going to zest one entire lemon and you
want to do this at the end because you
don't want them to get brown you want
them to keep that bright vibrant green
color if you feel like you have a firmer
lemon a good tip is just to give it a
little roll and add the lemon juice
these guys are looking good just give
them a little toss
and i'm going to hit them with a little
bit of salt i think we're ready to go
okay
last thing we're gonna make is the gravy
so i have one cup of my turkey drippings
and water basically drippings are just
all those juices we were basting the
turkey in and all of those yummy smells
from our aromatics all of that and then
this dripping which is going to make
this gravy taste like we really put some
effort into it so we're literally going
to boil them boil out the water boil out
anything we don't need and everything
that's left is going to be very highly
concentrated it's going to be thick rich
i think my gravy is good one thing i
like to do is put a little spoon in it
if it coats to back your spoon
it will coat your meat which means you
are all good to go all right this gravy
is done i'm gonna go plate everything
and we're gonna see if it actually
tastes good or if it tastes like i spent
30 so
let's go try it
[Music]
this
is what
29.93
worth of food looks like i was able to
make the mashed potatoes with real
butter and sour cream so i got that tang
i got my dairy in there i was able to
make this stuffing which is surprisingly
really really really beautiful and we
got a nice crunch to it it looks good it
looks like it took us a lot of time
green beans just to liven up the party
we needed some freshness y'all we have
to eat some vegetables in this pot do
y'all see did y'all see the spot the pie
is stunning it looks like i actually
really really took my time and as far as
my guests know i did surprisingly i
actually had enough money to add a
little bit of cranberry sauce and i just
added some orange zest to it to give it
the extra oomph all right so i got my
plate quality control time so i'm gonna
give this turkey a try okay you guys
this is not bad like for the price point
this is actually pretty good i'm trying
my mashed potatoes
okay those are amazing anything with a
cup and a half of butter and it should
be amazing and it is i'm very proud of
this
what's up everybody i'm david and you
know i love to cook but only on a budget
so today i'm gonna try to make a dollar
dish picnic for two for only fourteen
dollars everybody this is the haul looks
pretty good to me we've got a wide
variety of stuff to make an amazing
summer picnic here we actually came in
under budget while we were looking to
spend only 14 we spent
13.37 cents now along with all of this
we're going to use some of our pantry
staples today we're going to use flour
sugar olive oil salt and pepper i'm
really excited to get to it so let's go
ahead and jump into the first recipe
alright so to get started we're going to
make a fresh corn salad now this is a
great addition to have because corn is
inexpensive it's in season right now and
it's a nice delicious hearty side to
have now the first thing we're going to
do is pickle some onions we're going to
do that with a little bit of olive oil
some lemon juice a little bit of salt
real quick just a little half one and
then of course some sugar in there the
pickling of the onions is gonna do two
things for us take out a little bit of
that bite because it can be a little
strong so that it just blends better
with everything in case you don't like
that and we didn't have enough money to
buy vinegar so it's gonna help us make a
little salad dressing as well all right
this is looking pretty good and the next
thing we're going to do is boil our corn
so we're going to bring some salted
water to a boil and place the corn in
there for just about five minutes some
people tend to overcook their corn
boiling it for 10 or 15 minutes you can
always tell if you've left it in too
long if it starts to wrinkle now you can
eat corn raw so honestly all you need is
about five or so minutes and you'll be
good to go all right now that our corn
finish boiling we're going to go ahead
and cut it and prep it to go into our
salad you also want to make sure that
you don't handle them until they're cool
to the touch so you don't burn yourself
typically when people cut corn you'll
see them stand it up like this
but i'm going to recommend that you go
ahead and just lay it on its side and
the paper towel will help you keep it
stabilized and it's also going to help
catch those kernels so they don't fly
everywhere whenever i'm cooking and
stuff's flying everywhere it gets on my
nerves i know you probably feel the same
so you're going to go ahead and just
very carefully
cut down the sides
and if we're lucky
we'll get some nice little pieces like
this that we can put into our bowl
now that the corn is done we'll add some
fresh tomatoes even got a little avocado
on the budget you know on the lookout
for you our pickled onions
a little bit of salt
a little pepper now mix all that
together and then transfer it into a
bowl for a backyard picnic or tupperware
so you can have it on the go we're just
going to drizzle a little bit of olive
oil on there put a nice little pie
out of salt on there
and of course get a little fresh ground
pepper and that is our fresh tomato corn
salad it's colorful filling and
refreshing now it's time to spice things
up let's go ahead and move on to our
main course
and now i'm going to make a spicy fried
chicken it's a delicious hearty addition
travels well and it's delicious at room
temp we're going to go ahead and get
started with a nice two ingredient
marinade here i'm going to take my hot
sauce and put it into the sour cream and
then just gonna whisk it together now
we're gonna use sour cream instead of
buttermilk because it's a little bit
cheaper and it's still gonna give us
that nice little tang now that that's
mixed together we're gonna go ahead and
season our chicken we're gonna take a
little bit of salt we're using chicken
thighs with the bone in
as well as having the skin on because
that's going to be a little bit cheaper
and the dark meat always provides a
really nice flavor and a little bit of
pepper for these now that we've got
these all seasoned we're going to go
ahead and transfer them into our
marinade make sure you get every piece
nicely coated i'm gonna go ahead and
cover this with some plastic wrap and
let it marinate in the fridge for about
one to two hours if you have more time
you can let it marinate overnight now
it's time to fry some chicken so as you
can see we've got our marinated chicken
that we were working on earlier and a
little bit of flour now sometimes you
want to add a little kick but you don't
have all the money to get all the
various spices you'll need so we found a
seasoning packet this one's a buffalo
flavor to add just a little bit more
heat a little bit of a kick to it so
what we're going to do is
tear that open and put just a little bit
to the side you know about a teaspoon or
something because we want to use that
later so that we can garnish our chicken
and go ahead and put the rest of it into
your flour and you're going to mix that
up i'm going to go ahead and take these
beautiful chicken thighs you're going to
put them directly into your flour you
want to dredge them in the flour and
make sure that they get evenly coated
directly from that flour
carefully place it into the oil as you
can see we've got a cast iron skillet
that's going to allow us to do a shallow
fry save a little bit more of the oil we
bought and that retains heat amazingly
works really well we're going to get a
really nice crisp on our chicken we've
heated up our oil to about 350 or so
degrees we're going to let these bad
boys fry we're only gonna do about two
at a time here because we wanna make
sure we don't crab the pan because if
you add too much chicken you're not
gonna have enough time to cook evenly
and give you that nice crisp that you're
looking for all right now that we're
finished we're gonna go ahead and let
these drain on a paper towel and while
they're still hot we're going to use
that leftover seasoning we had
and go ahead and garnish with a little
bit of that we're going to go ahead and
place these in a little basket put them
in a box whatever is clever and with
that we have our flavorful spicy fried
chicken now let's end things on a sweet
note with dessert
today we're going to make some
strawberry shortcake jars and strawberry
shortcake is refreshing and i mean why
not so i got lucky and found these mini
biscuits for only a dollar which is
perfect because that's all i really need
for the two of us we'll go ahead open it
up
it's my favorite part and we've got a
baking sheet lined with parchment paper
help us to make sure they don't stick
when we take them out we're just going
to put these into the oven and follow
the directions on the can it says about
400 degrees for 8 to 11 minutes or until
they're nice and golden brown on the top
let's go pop these in the oven now
another reason we're making strawberry
shortcake is that we found these
strawberries on sale for only a dollar
and 56 cents for an entire pound now i
want to show you a little trick that we
used when we prep our strawberries
if you can take a metal straw like this
and insert it through the bottom
then the stem just pops right out if you
have a little excess that's all right
just tear it off
then you'll chop it
and throw it in there with the rest
you want to make sure to drizzle with
just a little bit of sugar to make it a
little sweet and it's going to bring out
the juices in the strawberries when we
add it to our jar it'll make a nice
little strawberry syrup for those
biscuits to soak up all right our
biscuits are ready first we're going to
chop up these biscuits now i recommend
taking it and kind of trying to cut it
in half first
then laying it flat
cutting across spinning it one more time
and that'll give you some nice little
bite-sized cubes throw those into a bowl
we've got these really cool glass jars
which are going to be perfect for after
we assemble everything so you can see
all the beautiful layers now you're
going to start out with your chopped
biscuits then we'll add our strawberries
you want to try to work from the outside
layer in
and then we're going to add the whipped
cream now you don't have to use a piping
bag but i think it's kind of cool pretty
easy and i wanted to feel fancy so we'll
just squeeze that in there it's a little
bit messy so i'm just going to smooth
that out i'm going to go ahead and add
some more of our biscuits and for me
it doesn't have to look pretty as long
as it tastes good some more of our fresh
strawberries on there we'll end with our
whipped topping
we're going to put just a little bit of
our biscuits on top as a little garnish
and a nice little strawberry on the side
now these strawberry shortcake jars
actually get even better the longer they
sit because that strawberry syrup is
just gonna sop and soak into those
biscuits and make it even more amazing
it's the perfect picnic dessert because
they look taste and smell just like
summer well everyone this is our dollar
dish picnic for two and we were able to
execute it for under 14
we've got a fresh corn tomato salad
we've got some delicious spicy fried
chicken and our strawberry shortcake jar
now uh before i go i gotta make sure and
do some quality control let's see how
this came out
that's good
that extra little seasoning on top gave
it the perfect little kick i gotta wrap
all this up
take it home me and amanda are gonna
have a backyard picnic
as you can see i've already went
shopping and we got some pretty good
deals here now i did go a little bit
over budget but i think we still did
pretty good the total only came out to
twenty dollars and forty three cents as
always we're going to use a few of our
pantry freebies today we're going to be
using olive oil sugar salt and pepper
well with that let's get started
now we're going to start with this
pineapple barbecue bacon burger now
these are going to be pretty epic i mean
it's wrapped in bacon and stuffed with
cheese what more could you want the
first step is going to be to take your
ground beef and just season it to taste
with a little salt maybe about one and a
half pie house or something like that
you know nothing crazy and do the same
with your pepper make sure that you use
enough since this is going to be for all
four burgers now we're going to go ahead
and start to incorporate this seasoning
together just use your hands and work it
in really good
and then we'll put in about a cup of
barbecue sauce i want to make sure we
get all of that in there
now we chose burgers because ground beef
tends to be a little bit cheaper and
it's always a fan favorite and when you
stuff it with cheese everybody's going
to be happy now after you've got your
meat ready you want to go ahead and
section it off into about four pieces so
that you can have four big juicy burgers
they're gonna be big we're gonna give
you that little fast food burger you'd
be having at your cousin barbecue you go
home hungry don't nobody like that and
after you get it worked into a nice
little ball we'll place it onto our
baking sheet
so then you can use a soda can or beer
can whatever you have around the house
to help you make that little crater
where we'll fill our cheese
so i'm going to go ahead and just smash
it down in there
and you want to make sure that you try
to build it up around the sides so that
you don't have any cracks in it and then
we'll take our bacon
you know go ahead and just slide that
around
it's going to get to bubbling and
baking in all over the place now you
know we're generous here so we're going
to use two strips wrap that around and
now once you've got it all nice and
wrapped you want to take a toothpick and
just insert it wherever the bacon
overlaps so it'll stay together as it
cooks so one right there then i'm gonna
put another one on the other side
and maybe one more over here just to be
safe and then you can lift out your can
and you should have a nice little crater
for your cheese now we decided to get a
block of cheddar cheese and cut it
ourselves rather than getting some
shredded cheese or pre-cut cheese
because it's a little cheaper we're just
gonna repeat that step three more times
and we'll be ready to put these bad boys
on the grill got my burgers ready
i've got my pineapple slices i was lucky
enough to find a fresh pineapple went
ahead and cut it into four slices so we
have one for each burger and now we're
ready to go let's get these on the grill
so we've got our grill up to about 375
degrees i'm going to place these burgers
over indirect heat now what that means
is we've got this left side of the grill
turned off and the right side we have
both burners on so when we close it it's
going to act just like an oven but still
give you that nice charred flavor that
we're looking for
all right
we're going to baste these with the
barbecue sauce every 10 to 15 minutes
you want to go ahead and just drizzle
dabble and just let that flavor get in
there as it caramelizes and cooks really
nice and now we're going to place our
pineapples over direct heat we've used a
little paper towel just to remove some
of the excess water to make sure we get
some really nice grill marks mmm
already smells good
and we'll just let these pineapple
slices cook for about one to two minutes
per side until we have some nice grill
marks
i'm baking these for the second time
these guys are looking good
now let's go prep our sides
now i know when you're thinking
hamburgers you're thinking fries but i
wanted to put just a little bit of a
healthy spin on it besides string beans
are pretty much the french fries and
vegetables so we've got some string
beans and some potato wedges we're going
to put together now to get started with
our potato wedges you're just going to
take your potato already peeled put it
up on the side like this and cut it down
the middle now you can take that and
just cut it into some nice sized wedges
like so now we're going to take those
wedges and place them into our bowl
now when you're on a budget salt and
pepper your friend don't be all fancy
trying to get the pink himalayan and all
that this you know nice sea salt does
just fine and today i'm excited because
we got garlic parmesan that's my
favorite thing to put on wings and all
types of things i'm gonna be generous
with this one because i like it
go ahead and get that well up in there
now just make sure you get everything
coated really nicely the olive oil salt
pepper and seasoning so that it grills
really nice
we'll do the same with our potato wedges
smells amazing already
and with that i think these are ready
for the grill
now that our burgers have about 15
minutes left we're gonna go ahead and
get our sides on now with these potato
wedges we're gonna throw them on the
grill for about five to seven minutes
per side
that garlic parmesan seasoning packet is
gonna come in perfect i can already
smell the flavor and now for our green
beans
make sure all your veggies have even
contact with the grill we don't want to
overcrowd it so if it takes a couple
batches that's fine
we'll cook these potato wedges for about
five to seven minutes per side you'll
know they're done once you can see the
beautiful grill marks and they're easy
to pierce with a fork now that our
veggies are done we'll go ahead and get
these burgers off the grill and assemble
them alright it's time to put these
burgers together we're going to go ahead
and start with just a little bit of
lettuce on the bottom
and then we'll go ahead and get that
delicious burger
oozing with cheese
and last but not least that beautiful
charred pineapple all right
everyone's for sure gonna love these
now that our burgers are put together
we're gonna go ahead and put our side
into a nice little bowl i've decided to
garnish it with a little bit of lemon
yes splurged a little bit and got one
and we can go ahead and put some fresh
lemon juice on the top just for another
nice flavor so at this point i think i
deserve a taste let's go ahead and see
what we're working with here
definitely got to get some of these
delicious green beans
of course i'm going to need one of these
amazing burgers all right this is pretty
big so i'm going to go ahead and cut it
in half so i can actually get a bite out
of it now that looks like heaven
[Music]
we were able to find a nice variety of
stuff and we're going to actually make
three different menu items today we're
going to have a cream cheese stuffed
monkey bread a mixed green salad with an
orange dressing as well as a blt eggs
benedict of course i'll be using a few
pantry items these are things we always
keep stocked in a tasty kitchen today
we'll be using salt pepper butter and
oil i'm excited to dive in and i hope my
friends are going to be impressed with
that said let's get cooking so the first
thing we're going to be making is the
cream cheese stuffed monkey bread what
i'm going to do is go ahead and add a
little bit of cinnamon to my sugar here
we'll use this in a bit after we put
together
our cinnamon rolls and get them ready
for the pan you want to just kind of mix
that in there so we have that nice light
brown color and we'll put that off to
the side for now now we're going to use
some cinnamon roll dough today because i
wanted to make a super easy and quick
dessert to add to my brunch i'm gonna go
ahead and get it open
oh all right looks like the cinnamon
rolls had a little bit of pie out of
themselves now you'll want to cut them
in half
so that you have almost a sort of moon
shape bring these two sides together
flatten it down with your finger until
it's basically back into a circle again
and we have about four ounces of cream
cheese here that we've cut into some
cubes you'll take one of the small cubes
place it into the center wrap the
cinnamon roll around it roll it between
your hands and then we'll use that
cinnamon sugar that we made earlier just
kind of toss it in there make sure it's
well covered can't forget to
get a little pam into our baking dish
now that that's been greased we can go
ahead and finish covering our cinnamon
roll ball and the cinnamon sugar drop
that in there you want to place this to
the side and we can make a few more to
layer in the pan now we're going to make
a bit of a caramel sauce to add to this
just to make it a little bit more rich
and give it a really nice flavor and for
this it's super simple we're just going
to use a little bit of brown sugar and
some warm butter now you want to whisk
this very well try to get all of that
butter incorporated into the brown sugar
there's a couple of lumps in there it's
no problem just keep on mixing with your
whisk until you get a little bit more of
a smooth consistency now we're going to
pour this over the top and then give us
a really nice sweet glaze that looks
good now we'll go ahead and pour this
over our mixture try to get an even pour
as much as you can but again in the oven
it's going to caramelize the sugar in
there and it'll spread nice throughout
all right that looks good
we're going to put this in the oven at
350 for about 35 to 40 minutes and then
when we get back i'll show you what
we're going to do with the icing that
came with our cinnamon rolls
all right guys our monkey bread is
finished and looks amazing when you take
it out of the oven make sure that you
let it sit for about 5-10 minutes or
until it's cooled to the touch then you
can invert it onto a plate like this and
we'll go ahead and get started with our
icing now another tip would be the
reason that we use that cinnamon roll is
because it comes with the icing of its
own so we're going to just spoon this
into a small microwave-safe dish warm it
up for about 30 seconds or so and we're
going to drizzle it along the top for
again another piece of nice presentation
so since we had two cans we've got
plenty of icing for this monkey bread i
will make sure that i get every last
drop because this is dollar dish and we
will make sure that we get our money's
worth a little bit of frosting trying to
hide from it we're just gonna scrape him
out all right i've got all of the icing
out i'm gonna go ahead and microwave it
for about 30 seconds and when i come
back we're going to drizzle it on top of
the monkey bread
all right now we've got our icing just a
little bit more workable and i'm going
to drizzle this across the monkey bread
for our final touch
this glaze definitely makes the monkey
bread look perfect it's so indulgent
rich smells amazing now it's probably
going to be a good idea to balance this
out with a little salad or something
i'll be right back and we'll get started
on that
next up we're going to make a mixed
green salad with an orange dressing
we've got two oranges which are actually
going to be doing double duty we'll
segment them to place on top of the
salad and also juice them to make a nice
citrusy dressing so how we're going to
do this is take two small cuts first
you're going to cut off the top
and the bottom
and this will give us a more sturdy
workspace we don't have the orange
moving around when you're trying to do a
more difficult cutting technique now
you'll take your knife and place it just
under the skin
and try to work it down and around now
i'm not a pro so don't feel bad if
you're not able to make this perfect we
really just want to try to make sure
that we save as much of the fruit there
as possible and just get off all of that
peel now that we've got our oranges
cleaned up we're going to go back in
with our paring knife and try to cut out
these segments you want to aim for the
space right in between these membranes
that you see
also it's very important to try to cut
angle down at a v from both sides
this way the segment will free itself
after you get that out we'll place it
into our bowl here to be used later you
can just keep going around and slowly
cut those pieces out this is going to
add a really nice color to our salad and
be delicious for our dressing when we
juice the rest of it now once you're
finished you want to take everything
that you have left
and squeeze it with the juices into your
larger bowl because we're going to use
that to make our dressing in a little
bit we're going to repeat the process
with our second orange get all those
wonderful juices in there for our
dressing and finish up this salad all
right now we've got everything set up
here to put together our salad and we're
going to get started with the dressing
first things first i'm going to put this
orange juice into a cup make sure you
use a strainer just in case a few pieces
of those segments got in we're only
going to need about a quarter cup of
orange juice here after that we're going
to want to put in our lemon juice and
our sugar and then we'll put this in the
microwave for about 60 seconds until the
sugar dissolves all right now that we've
got the sugar dissolved we're going to
go ahead and mix in our olive oil make
sure you whisk all of this olive oil in
there now we'll want to put just a
little pinch of salt
about back out
just two pie houses this time not too
much
and depending on your taste
a few cracks of pepper
and that should be good to go now i'm
gonna put these to the side as i
assemble the rest of my salad
we want to make sure to reserve just
about a handful of these mixed greens so
we can also use them with our blt eggs
benedict now i've got some nice avocados
here because i mean what's a brunch in
california without avocados those
segmented oranges that we worked with
earlier again just gonna add another
beautiful color to this salad some red
onions for a nice little crunch that
should do it and last but not least i've
got some nice honey roasted nuts here
that we just chopped up and i found
these pretty much in the checkout aisle
where you'll see those little
grab-and-go kind of snacks i think it's
just going to give another nice little
sweet flavor to the end of our salad and
again make it look a little bit more
fancy than it is it's a dollar dish
trend right there i'm not going to quite
put the salad dressing on yet i want to
make sure that i toss that within the
salad right before we plate everything
and now it's time for the last recipe
everyone's going to be here soon so
let's make that eggs benedict
now i'm definitely excited to make this
blt eggs benedict to get started we're
going to go ahead and make our english
muffins
we're going to take this bad boy
slice it in half and place it onto our
pan
like so so we're only actually gonna use
three of these and have some extras left
over in the package so you have more to
use for meal prep the next week or just
to make another meal that's another one
of our dollar dish tips and now we're
going to move on to the bacon we're
going to use about two slices for each
of our eggs benedict so you don't want
to take these and just line them across
your pan now we could have gone with the
typical eggs benedict but we thought
that this little addition of the bacon
was going to give it just another nice
flavor and our fun little twist that
we'll put on a classic brunch dish and
now that we've got them ready we're
going to bake these in the same oven at
350 degrees fahrenheit we'll put our
english muffins in for about five
minutes and our bacon in for about 12 to
15 minutes until it's crispy and golden
brown all right now it's time to poach
our eggs we're going to be using these
eggs here which are again a staple
within our dollar dish meals because
eggs are relatively inexpensive they're
filling and you can use them within a
lot of different dishes today we're
going to use them for the poached egg
within our eggs benedict as well as
within our hollandaise sauce now since
poaching eggs can be difficult we're
going to teach you a hack using this
muffin tin you can poach a lot of eggs
save a lot of time and it can be done a
lot quicker now the first thing you're
going to do is grease your pan you want
to make sure that you put a little bit
more than you think you'll need just so
that we don't have the egg white
sticking to the side of the muffin tin
now we're going to crack our eggs in but
you want to be very careful because you
don't want to break the yolk
all right now that we've got our eggs
ready we're going to add a little bit of
salt and a little bit of pepper
we'll finish off with just a quick six
little payout
and one more paella
wanted to be gentle on that one and now
one of the most important parts you're
going to add one tablespoon of water to
each one of the muffin tins that has
your egg now you don't want to just drop
the water on top you want to try to
spread it out around the entire egg so
that it forms that egg bath and if you
have extra go ahead and put it on top in
the middle now we're going to place
these in the oven at 350 degrees
fahrenheit for about seven to nine
minutes or until that egg white is firm
and the yolk still has that nice runny
texture all right now we've got
everything ready to assemble our eggs
benedict the first thing i'm going to do
is take my english muffins here and add
just a little bit of butter on there so
it has a nice rich flavor at the base
after that we're going to go ahead and
add the mixed greens that i reserved
from our salad to add a little bit of
nice color and flavor to our bltx
benedict we got the bacon the lettuce
the tomato i gotta put the ale in my blt
eggs benedict now that l stands for both
love and lettuce just kind of distribute
those evenly it doesn't have to be a
whole bunch on any one of them now we're
gonna put the tomato this will act as a
nice little surface for our bacon and
our egg
now for the bacon we'll take these and
just kind of break them in half so that
we can fit them on a little bit nicer
and you'll take two pieces for every
eggs benedict now we're ready for the
egg
you're going to want to tip it over a
little to try to let some of that water
bath run off
and place it on top all right last one
the pressure is on
careful
oh that was close all right now we're
going to put together our hollandaise
sauce seems simple but you want to make
sure that you're careful as you put this
together we're going to start with a few
egg yolks in our blender and then we'll
add our lemon juice
and you want to blend this for about a
minute or so until you see a pale yellow
color
now that we've got the eggs nice and
ready we're going to go ahead and start
to add this melted butter
now you want to very slowly pour this in
as it continues to blend
now we're talking very slow the heat of
the blender in the butter will help to
cook those eggs and finish off our sauce
now that it's almost together we'll add
just a pinch of salt for taste and that
looks perfect now you're going to want
to make sure that you pour this on and
serve it immediately it's going to have
a nice
thick texture and you just want to put a
nice generous serving on each one it
adds a really nice beautiful shine to
the top as well which you're always
looking for when you make that eggs
benedict
and we're just about ready for my
friends to come try this out now a lot
of times people will top this off with
some fresh chives or some paprika but
that's not in the dollar dish budget so
we're just gonna crack a little bit of
our free pantry item pepper on here
all right my friends will be here any
minute so i've got to get everything
else ready so they can try this
wonderful branch all right well i've got
to say i'm pretty impressed with what
we've been able to put together here for
only 20 dollars everything's ready we've
got this decadent cream cheese filled
monkey bread this wonderful mixed green
salad with a nice orange dressing and
our blt eggs benedict
and two of my friends showed up a little
early so at this point i'm gonna go
ahead and see what they think
hello how are you doing cooking cooking
i mean he's trying to do my thing you
know how are you doing how are you good
good to see you this is a spread wow
it's beautiful yeah that doesn't mean
like two eggs muffins or something nah
nah we really try to go hard on dollar
dish you know we look good yeah let me
stop talking and just let you guys try
it yeah i feel like this needs to be
like a holiday or something let's eat
i like how when when you could taste
fresh things i was just like explodes in
your mouth it's a party going on all
those flavors let me hop into this blt
though i'm go ahead
[Music]
you